[Music]
5 25 on your friday morning what's cool
at school how about a classroom based
thank you for your service
five more schools in the silver state
have been named purple star schools
nevada department of education says that
designation is a sign that that school
supports the social and emotional
well-being of military students who have
to adjust not only to new schools but
also the absence of a deployed parent
the newest purple star schools are the
choral academy of science in las vegas
coronado high school
mountain view lutheran
triggs elementary and watson elementary
state superintendent joan ebert says
quote our military service members and
their families contribute to our
communities in so many ways we look
forward to identifying additional
schools that excel in providing them
with the support they need
and deserve
congrats to the newest purple star
schools now earlier this year becker
middle school and the gibson leadership
academy were the first to get the honor
if you know something that's cool at
school let us know you'll find cool at
school under the community tab of our
website 8newsnow.com or you can just
send us an email coolant school at
8newsnow.com